a rivalry so intense it set production
behind by almost 2 weeks when these
actors went their separate ways they
left with no regrets and no intentions
to
reunite shy lauff has attracted his fair
share of controversy in his career and
entire headlines have been dedicated to
the Transformers actors reported
conflicts with his co-stars one of his
strangest bust-ups happened on the 2013
Broadway production orphans which he
departed after an issue with Alec
Baldwin according to Baldwin's comments
to New York Magazine there had been
problems from the beginning since lauff
had already memorized his lines while
Baldwin hadn't Baldwin alleged that his
co-star reacted aggressively to him in
rehearsal so The Hunt for Red October
actor pulled aside director Dan Sullivan
and said someone needed to exit offering
to depart the project altogether however
the director chose to fire Leff instead
Baldwin also accused the director of
duplicity and not being entirely
committed to the production labuff
responded by posting screenshots of his
email correspondences with both Baldwin
and Sullivan confirming that there had
been exchanges regarding Baldwin's lack
of preparation for the play and the
director acknowledging that they were
incompatible as
performers after lighting up the early
2000s with memorable roles in fan
favorite films such as Freaky Friday and
Mean Girls Lindsay Lohan hit the
headlines for all the wrong reasons
toward the end of the decade wherever
she went controversy seemed to follow
and looh and became known more for her
escapades than her on-screen
performances in 2008 she showed up as
Kimmy Keegan in four episodes of Ugly
Betty one of the most popular shows on
TV at the time Lohan was scheduled to
perform in six episodes but her
appearances were cut down to four as per
page six the reason for this change was
reportedly due to Lohan's Behavior which
rubbed Ugly Betty star America Ferrera
the wrong way the publication shared
claims from an onset Insider who alleged
that that Lohan acted like a diva on set
and exhibited bizarre behavior whenever
she was around however an unnamed friend
of Lohan argued against these
allegations stating America was mean to
Lindsay producers give her too much
power Lindy didn't do the last two
episodes because America didn't like her
and got her kicked off I would really
really like to help you it's just you
know there aren't really any openings
here whatever the case may be it's clear
these two would not be working together
again action movie fans ate well in 2015
thanks to George Miller's Mad Max Fury
Road in this long overdue continuation
of the popular film series Tom Hardy
replaced Mel Gibson as Max Rockin tansy
while chariz Daren was introduced as
imperator furiosa the film won six
Academy Awards in the hearts of film
lovers around the world while it might
have been a masterpiece on screen it was
the opposite behind the scenes party and
theren created magic as their characters
but the real life people had problems
that boiled over on set Vanity Fair
published a shocking excerpt from Kyle
Buchanan's book Blood Sweat and chrome
the Wild and true story of Mad Max Fury
Road which painted a terrifying picture
of the breakdown in Hardy and thon's
relationship the working relationship
between hardy and theren was strained to
the point where producer was called out
to help get them on the same page one
day Hardy arrived late on set and theen
went off on him Hardy stormed over to
her and there was fear of physical
altercation camera operator Mark giln
said he was quite aggressive she really
felt threatened and that was the turning
point because then she said I want
someone as protection she then had a
producer that was assigned to be with
her all the time the actors have both
expressed regret over their behavior at
the time but they have also avoided
working together since then one of the
most infamous feuds in Hollywood
involves sex and the city co-stars Kim
katrol and Sarah Jessica Parker while
the two might have starred in a
television show that will go down in
history for what it did for the medium
the tension between the actors
manifested for the longest time with
katrol reportedly ostracized from the
rest of the cast still the ladies put
aside whatever animosity they had to
film the movies after the show had ended
when we're not doing that the show we
just really don't want to see each other
when katrol decided she was done with
the character and wasn't interested in
ret turning for a third film the gloves
were off after she posted about the
death of her brother on Instagram Parker
reached out to offer her sympathy
however katrol responded with a public
call out on Instagram writing your
continuous reaching out is a painful
reminder of how cruel you really were
then and now let me make this very clear
if I haven't already you were not my
family you were not my friend so I'm
writing to tell you one last time to
stop exploiting our tragedy in order to
restore your nice girl Persona a Revival
of Sex in the City titled and just like
that premiered in 2021 but katrol wasn't
approached to reprise her role nor did
her castmates expect her to however she
did return for a cameo in season too
though she didn't interact with the rest
of the cast Shirley mlan and Anthony
Hopkins are widely regarded as two of
the finest actors of their generation
and perhaps even of all time they have
dazzled audiences with countless awe
inspiring performances throughout the
decades and they even collaborated in
the 1980 comedy drama a change of
seasons unfortunately their team up
wasn't as successful as some might have
imagined the film received the kind of
nominations no performer ever dreams of
Razzy nominations Hopkins apparently
wasn't too impressed by his co-star
referring to mlan as quote the most
obnoxious actor mlan responded to his
report in a 2014 interview with the New
York post saying I didn't like him
either but he was on the wagon at the
time and it was hard on him mlan and
Hopkins have avoided sharing the screen
since then presumably for good
reason as two of the most recognizable
actors in the world you'd expect that
there would be a little healthy
competition between Brad Pit and Tom
Cruz even so they combined their powers
to make 1994's Oscar nominated Interview
with the Vampire which is generally
considered one of the best vampire films
of all time yet while pits Lewis and
Cruz's leat were Blood Brothers on
screen it doesn't appear like the same
sentiment was shared when the camera
stopped rolling pit has gone on record
to discuss how generally unhappy he was
during the shoot for the movie but it
also wasn't helped by his co-star
according to Radar Online pit supposedly
said he bugged me there came a point
during filming when I started really
resenting him he's North Pole I'm South
he's always coming in at you with a
handshake whereas I may bump into you
there was this underlying competition
that got in the way of any real
conversation before pit and Cruz wrapped
up Interview with the Vampire there was
a point when the former tried to depart
the project before finding out the
financial impact it would have in the
end he stayed on but he and Cruz have
largely remained out of each other's
orbit since then Bill Murray and Harold
Ramos are best known for playing Peter
vinman and Egon Spangler in the
Ghostbusters movies but the two teamed
uped for many other projects as well as
a writer and director Ramos often turned
to Murray for his film since they were
close friends and worked well together
not surprisingly he cast Murray in the
lead role of TV weatherman Phil Connor
in the 1993 comedy groundhog day however
the movie created a rift between the two
friends that lasted for two decades the
problem started when Murray and Ramos
had disagreements about the creative
direction of the film this resulted in
tension between the two on set which
also affected their personal
relationship discussing the production
with the New Yorker rayus said at times
bill was just really irrationally mean
and unavailable he was constantly late
on set what I'd want to say to him is
just what we tell our children you don't
have to throw Tantrums to get what you
want just say what you want RIS said
that Murray simply stopped speaking to
him after Groundhog Day in her book
Ghostbusters daughter life with my dad
Harold RIS Violet Ramos revealed that
Murray and her father did manage to
reconcile before Harold's death in
2014 I thought you might turn up
whenever Seth Rogan and Jonah Hill team
up for a movie it should be expected
that it won't be PG-13 in 2013's this is
the end they amped up the runchy humor
and got wild with a lot of their Pals
including actors like Danny McBride and
Channing Tatum Emma Watson also cameoed
in the film but but there was one scene
that proved to be too much for her so
she Departed the set according to an
extra who spoke to pop focal Watson
wasn't a big fan of a scene in which
Tatum was dressed in only a leather
thong The Source explained during the
scene Channing decided to do some of his
break dancing in front of her but alas
he was in nothing but a thong so Emma
storms off set reportedly Watson also
wasn't impressed that Tatum had been
drinking before filming the scene Rogan
was asked about the incident in a later
interview with GQ the actor confirmed
that it did happen but stressed that
there was no bad Vibe between them and
Watson even promoted the movie whether
or not that bad blood is really there it
seems unlikely we'll ever see the two
share a screen
again when Jim Carrey started as the
Riddler in Batman Forever he was at the
height of his big screen comedy career
however his co-star Tommy Lee Jones who
played Harvey two-faced Dent was
definitely not a fan of Carri slapstick
sty
director Joel Schumer confirmed that
Jones had an attitude on set telling
Entertainment Weekly in
1996 Jim Carrey was a gentleman and
Tommy Lee was threatened by him I'm
tired of Defending overpaid
overprivileged actors the night before
filming a scene together Carrie and
Jones ran into each other at a
restaurant when Carrie approached
Jones's table to say hello he didn't get
quite the greeting he expected Carrie
told Howard Stern he got up kind of is
shaking and hugged me and said I hate
you I really don't like you and I was
like wow what's going on man and he said
I cannot sanction your
buffoonery that is if you'll spare my
life for just a few months at the height
of their popularity both Marlon Brando
and Valk Kilmer had to deal with
accusations of being Divas on set
putting them together in a movie where
both wrestled for the title of top dog
was always is going to be interesting
much has been documented about the
1996's the island of Dr Moro and it
appears that the Stars didn't do much to
help it was a troubled production in
which director Richard Stanley was
removed after just a few days on set his
replacement John frankenheimer told
Entertainment Weekly I don't like Val
Kilmer I don't like his work ethic and I
don't want to be associated with him
ever again allegedly Brando wasn't a fan
of Kilmer either and he importantly told
the younger star your problem is you
confuse your talent with the size of
your paycheck according to the sources
Kilmer was continuously late to set a
habit Brando later picked up the
production lost almost 2 weeks worth of
shooting as a result in a Reddit AMA
session years later Kilmer praised his
time working with Brandon and was only
complimentary of him as a performer and
person the Batman Forever actor
suggested that most of the publicized
issues surrounding the island of Dr Moro
were a result of the executives and
director trying to save face and divert
attention
elsewhere